hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to we put
up with some pretty weird shit in our
childhoods did we we had midget bears
that made people feel better by shooting
out their radioactive stomachs premature
reptiles that state ninjitsu while
eating processed Italian food and then
alien who's knows quite frankly should
have been censored you know with all
that strangeness going on there is still
a few select moments that stick out in
the totally messed up Department these
are known as the mindfuck moments the
times when not only are you looking at
total craziness but it's constantly
being thrown at you and simply will not
let up it can be just a few moments or
can sometimes be the length of the
entire movie either way there's
absolutely nothing normal about it now
I've already mentioned the Tom Jerry
movie in another review and trust me
when I say that boarded atrocity doesn't
have to be mentioned again but there are
still 11 other choices that deserve to
be looked at and feared beyond reason so
in this special surreal edition of the
nostalgia critic
I'd like you to forget about your calm
logical reality and enter a world of
crazy insane fucked-up tivity this is
the top 11 nostalgic mindfuck
- OH
we won
Oh
number banette Toon Town from Who Framed
Roger Rabbit this is every kid's dream
come true and every adults worst
nightmare a world crawling with
completely insane cartoon characters at
first it sounds cool but when you really
get down to it a lot of your favorite
cartoon characters are fucking assholes
every other second something's either
shouting exploding or trying to kill you
it's like a week inattendue Jettas plus
it's probably the only time you'll see
Bugs Bunny and Mickey Mouse together
that alone is pretty surreal yeah so
house Pixar saving your ass this time
Mickey saw my enchanted bull sack you
hunk of shit
it was always bright and colorful file
is also manic and totally out of control
making a simple daytime stroll a freakin
fight for your life operating on cartoon
logic that is to say no logic toontown
definitely knew how to make us all
grateful to be living in the real world
toons gets them every time I'm a carrot
number below cool world this is a
horrible movie it makes no sense the
acting is horrible and nothing about it
is funny or dramatic but boy was it
fucked up creating a city of faces a
million violent residents and just to
make it as surreal as possible Brad Pitt
you're dealing with shit here that's way
over your head alright I can take the
madness and chaos of this world but Brad
Pitt for some reason that's just too far
he's surreal enough just being with
Angelina Jolie he doesn't need any help
from this movie I've heard it in borscht
Lee
looks like toontown cool world was
always loud and obnoxious but rather
than being bright and colorful gore was
dark and grainy creating one of the
coolest hell holes ever put on film
unfortunately does its job a little too
well by the time this movie was over I
grant for the exit like the screen was
on fire and judging by the images it was
hard to tell whether it was or not place
should be erased still even for all it's
nonsensical Anarchy cool world did have
well nonsense glam well I guess that is
something to be admired we may not be
real - yeah
yes yes yes number Z Dragon's Lair to
Time Warp now I know it's kind of
cheating putting a video game in the mix
but dragon's lair tree was a fully 2d
animated adventure and was still
enjoyable to watch even if you weren't
playing I liked the first arcade game
that simply put you in different rooms
in different situations Dragon's Lair -
actually moved like a story well sorry
there were actual levels instead of just
obstacles but they still didn't make
that much sense like the first level is
just escaping you're angry mother-in-law
how strange is that yo there's another
level where you're confused for Alice
from Alice in Wonderland was clearly
together by Kiko dick I implemented the
way float mimsy were the borogoves and
the mome Raths out later but the
strangest level balls got to be the
Baker you start off at the size of a
mouse as you're fighting off a cat in
Beethoven's house sounds basic enough
but look what happens as time goes by
Chuck what the hell why is the piano
flying why is the cat breathing fire and
why did Beethoven suddenly turn into
Elton John
we never get an answer for any of this
but to be honest the answers were
probably just infuse explore the
dragon's lair games were not only
intense to play but they were a trip to
watch making no sense whatsoever but
given the directors other projects I'd
say we've come to expect that and in
this case naturally porcupines are dog
next number under Tesla
the paraphernalia wagon from grinch
night the Grinch had a number of
spin-offs after how the Grinch Stole
Christmas including Grinch night the
Grinch Grinch is the Cat in the Hat and
probably the most controversial how the
grapes killed Horton but this was by far
the strangest of as all of who's done
who feel are afraid of the Grinch coming
down from his mountain and into the
neighborhood so it's up to a small boy
named Yuka Raya to stand up to the
Grinch and try to distract it why is he
coming to town because the wind has
changed why is everyone afraid of it
because he's the Grinch I guess ok so
this plot made absolutely no sense
whatsoever and given the stories of dr.
Seuss that's saying a lot on top of it
it's a very dialogue heavy special with
very little action or visuals Yuka Raya
said reap a Josiah and Grandpa Josiah
said yes yoga Riya and Eukarya said call
the Grinch alarm Center and Grandpa
Josiah say an excellent suggestion and
Eukarya says that is until the Grinch
opens up his Terrapin elia way or as I
went to call it hell
gotcha gotcha
myths and babe ah yeah I like The
Adventures of Sonic the Hedgehog though
all the creatures and visuals have
structured and are pretty impressive to
look at it you find your own take I just
wet myself logical no crazy nah fucked
up beyond all recognition
you bet your friggin ass rinche night is
one night on the town I think we'd all
like to forget sooner than later
now on to our next nut wait a bit this
is right
much better
number one Bragg the end and end a
musical adventure now I know what you're
thinking how can a movie based on a
prissy little doll have anything
resembling a my 5 moment well just watch
some of it coming is this endless eating
all that is to be brief and that is cuz
I love ya
this was a weird freakin movie with
bizarre characters and strange settings
it came out the 70s what a surprise and
was the first film to ever be based on
the doll so nobody really knew what to
do with it so they decided to do
anything they wanted to do with it
adding the strangest images ever to be
associated with the character I think
the strangest parts are probably
involving a blobfish creature called the
Gordy cause without a sweetheart I never
get in love and two naked dolls that do
um this scares me both kids were freaked
out by this movie which caused a whole
generation of kids to be scared by this
fucking thing even though it wasn't
really a good film and it was a huge
flop at the box office
it was certainly creative and give us a
whole shitload of things to freak our
minds over if you can believe it the
same guy who animated toontown was also
the director of this cool old fable I
know quite a stretch huh I never thought
I'd say this but after seeing this movie
Raggedy Ann is just plain fucked up
what if it isn't mr. puppy
hello mr. brother I'll knock down a
carafe number number opening to the
Beetlejuice cartoon
I'm convinced this show had the coolest
opening effort not only were the images
out there and deranged but the music
sounded like a group of Christmas
carolers singing at a fucking tilt
awhirl
look at all these weird creations that
just continue to fly out it if Tim
Burton had never done acid I'd hate to
see what happens if he does remember the
show itself being okay and you could
definitely call it a very strange series
let's just pumped up opening that always
got your attention
I could ask just watch this a dozen
times and probably be just as satisfied
as watching an episode it was kind of
like a Disney ride designed by the
Manson Family creepy kooky mysterious
and spooky the opening of eel juice knew
how to creep us out as well as hype us
up
I'm away the hallucination from beavis
and butt-head do America I know neither
the show nor the movie was intended for
kids but that didn't stop us from
watching it anyway and boy didn't lead
to one of the biggest trip out moments
ever it all starts when beavis and
butt-head are stranded in the desert as
Bemis takes a bite of a cactus that
causes him to start hallucinating and
what follows is that stammel is measured
now it's pretty well known that people
sin but it have never been very big in
the artistic regard but when they got
the designs of Rob Zombie's illustration
work the rest is mine fuck history and
as soon as it's over of course no one
ever mentions it again yeah okay damn it
actually a lot of these mic bugs are
essentially big-lipped alligator moments
but as long as they entertain a mess of
our perception of normality it's always
well
number duper Willy Wonka's tunnel from
hell yeah yeah I know I put this out
list already but this scene is just so
goddamn strange I can't imagine it again
I mean what is up with it the rest of
the movie is so charming and magical and
that all of a sudden were transported
into Satan's war song what was the point
I'm gonna be sick
there is no life I know to compare with
pure imagination living there you'll be
free if you truly I'm the pie this is
Halloween from The Nightmare Before
Christmas this is by far the best part
of the movie is the best song best
visuals and best out of your fucking
mind moment every second something is
flying it and in a world where
everything is designed to scare chances
are you're gonna come across in freaky
moments this world is so surreal that
bats actually had strings attached to
them whoa
that's just crazy all the creatures of
Halloween are in the opening and are all
recognizable except for one what the
hell is that guy he looks like a
chewed-up reject from where the wild
things are I mean what's he doing there
I am a Jimmy
while the whole movie is of course a
classic it's the song sequence that we
remember the most because it has the
most freaky ass shit common ass a few
years ago this film was released again
in theaters and presented in 3d
garnet I'm watching the 2d I don't need
three dimensions to tell me a fucked up
this is our chance - whether you're
scared by it or not this is Halloween
definitely rates a 9.5 on the Oaxaca
meter what number p ana the pink
elephants from Dumbo again this is a
perfectly normal kid's film that
suddenly takes a trip down LSD land in
the middle of the movie the scene starts
out with Dumbo getting drunk I just
realized how strange that's out we see
him start to blow bubbles with his trunk
as the bubbles start shape-shifting you
see mercy and then chaos a parade of
paint black eyed demons come phasing out
nowhere and decide to have a freakout
meet elephants on parade here they come
hippity hoppity elephant ivory where I
actually love watching this movie when
little kids are around because they
never know if they should be enchanted
or horrified chasing away chasing away
I'm afraid neater eight big elephants on
parade
I'm not pissing myself with fear but why
the scene just gets more and more
surreal until the final gangbang of
consciousness takes points
was it good for you totally out of
nowhere and totally making no sense pink
elephants was an ugly brain bash that no
amount of alcohol can make you forget as
a number theory of relativity nostalgic
mind fuck is the opening the pee-wee's
Playhouse somehow peewee keeps making it
on my top 11 list I don't know that's a
good thing we're bad but in this slot
it's definitely cold
the show starts off in the middle of the
forest and at first it's kind of
relaxing the music is very mellow
nothing much is really going on and you
see what your house would look like if
you were the richest owner in the world
but just as you're starting to relax
it goes into my fuck central where
literally everything in the house can
talk
the chairs o'clock the window everything
the only thing I never saw talking on
the show is the floor and that's because
I don't think it ever had anything to
say we also gave a song sung by a woman
or it's a hope it's a woman who sounds
like she just sucked a year's worth of
helium breathe and if you think this
little checking out of your sanity
doesn't last very long think again
most TV shows have an opening of about
30 seconds a minute at the most
pee-wee's Playhouse has an opening of
two and a half minutes
never once showing a single solitary
credit even introduction where
everything talks chipmunks are singing
and Laurence Fishburne wears a cowboy
suit isn't considered the ultimate mind
puck the quite frankly I think it's time
to get an intervention and those are the
top 11 nostalgic mind bucks well I think
it's time to return to reality I said I
think it's time to return to reality
Thank You terrifying logo I needed that
hey how come you didn't come out when I
mentioned the pink elephants oh it's
because I mentioned the S at the end
isn't it you only come out when I say
the word elephant elephant elephant
elephant elephant elephant I am in fun
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have to